trop brouillons pour certains pollution
visuelle pour d'autres depuis des années
les éoliennes électrise le débat c'est
un bruit
fatiga en quoi sans arrêt sans arrêt qui
tourne qui tombe du toit en france l'une
des premières éoliennes sort de terre en
c'était sur l'île d'ouessant en bretagne
l'expérience est plutôt bien accueillie
par les habitants
concernant de potentielles nuisances il
n'y a pas de quoi s'inquiéter selon le
maire de la commune
je ne pense pas que cela puisse a pu
apporter les perdu le chien au point de
vue bruit vis-à-vis des des habitations
voisines qui sont quand même à petit
sans être soumis qu'à partir des années
90 que les éoliennes se déploie
réellement sur le sol national la plus
grande de france s'est construite à
port-la-nouvelle dans l'aude et alimente
près de 100 maisons en électricité et
les riverains sont plutôt enthousiastes
c'est très très bien
d'abord chapeau ou pas ça n'abîme pas le
visage fin des années 90 des riverains
commencent à se plaindre face au
développement des éoliennes dans
certaines régions exemple en 1997 dans
la manche à dunkerque
neuf d'entre elles sont construites en
bord de mer et ça ça ne plaît pas
beaucoup aux promeneurs du dimanche tout
par rapport au paysage de la plage était
belle elle a eu quand même un certain
cachet malgré le fait des jeans derrière
et je trouve que c'est un peu dommage
pour le
même critique ac les tout petits dans la
manche en 2003 un parc éolien doit y
voir le jour à 600 mètres des premières
maisons trop près beaucoup trop près
selon ce riverain on demande ou un
kilomètre pour le bruit puisque on va s
ouvre pour la vue puisque vous voyez
très bien qu'on voit une personne de
boudin cette porte là bas pour nous ce
n'est pas supportable
aujourd'hui le débat autour des
éoliennes est toujours d'actualité
il s'est même invitée au coeur des
régionales marine le pen la présidente
du fn veut démolir certains équipements
de son côté l'ancien ministre de
l'écologie nicolas hulot a dénoncé une
récupération politique
[Musique]